according to the UN billions of people
still live without an address the
economist Hernando DeSoto said without
an address you live outside the law you
might as well not exist I'm here to tell
you how my team and I are trying to
change that if you go to an online map
and look at a favela in Brazil or a
Township in South Africa you'll see a
few streets but a lot of empty space but
if you've lived a satellite view there
are thousands of people homes and
businesses in this vast unmapped and
unaddressed faces in Ghana's capital
Accra there are numbers and letters
scrawled on to the size of walls where
they piloted address systems but not
finished in but these places these
unaddressed places hold huge economic
potential here's why the issue of
addressing stuck with me I worked in the
music business for ten years and well
you may not know about the music world
is that everyday people struggle with
the problems of addressing so from the
musicians you have to find the gigs to
the production companies who bring the
equipment everyone somehow always gets
lost we even had to add someone to our
schedules who was the person you called
when you thought you'd arrived but then
realized you hadn't and we had some
pretty bad days like in Italy where a
truck driver unloaded all the equipment
an hour north of Rome not an hour south
of Rome and a slightly worse day where a
keyboard player called me instead of
Chris don't panic but we may have just
sound checked at the wrong people's
wedding
so not long after the fated Rome event I
chatted this through with a friend of
mine who's a mathematician and we
thought it was a problem we could do
something about we thought what we could
make a new system but it shouldn't look
like the old system we agreed that
addresses were bad we knew we wanted
something very precise but GPS
coordinates latitude and longitude were
just too complicated so we divided the
world into three meter squares the world
divides into around 57 trillion 3 meter
squares and we found that there are
enough combinations of three dictionary
words that we could name every 3 meter
square in the world uniquely with just
three words we use 40,000 words so
that's 40,000 cubed 64 trillion
combinations of three words which is
more than enough for the 57 trillion odd
3 meter squares with a few spare so
that's exactly what we did we divided
the world into 3 meter squares gave each
one a unique three word identifier what
we call a three word address so for
example right here I'm standing at
mustards coupons pinup but over here I'm
standing a pinched singularly
tutorial but we haven't just done this
in English we thought it was essential
that people should be able to use this
system in their own language
so far we've built it into 14 languages
including French Swahili and Arabic and
we're working on more now like coaster
Zulu and Hindi but this idea can do a
lot more than just get my musicians to
their gigs on time if the 75 percent of
countries that struggle with reliable
addressing started using three word
addresses there's a stack of far more
important applications in Durban South
Africa an NGO called Gateway health have
distributed eleven thousand three word
address signs to their community so the
pregnant mothers when they go into labor
can call the emergency services and tell
them exactly where to pick them up for
because otherwise the ambulances have
often taken hours to find them in
Mongolia the national post service of a
table to the system
and are now doing deliveries to many
people's houses for the first time the
UN are using it to geotag photos in
disaster zones so they can deliver aid
to exactly the right place even Domino's
Pizza are using in the Caribbean because
they haven't been edifying customers
homes but they really want to get their
pizza to them while it's still hot
surely you'll be able to get into a car
speak for three words and the car will
navigate you to that exact spot in
Africa the continent has leapfrogged
phone lines to go mobile phones bypassed
traditional banks to go straight to
mobile payments we're really proud that
the post services of three African
countries Nigeria Djibouti and cote de
Foix have gone straight to adopting
three word addresses which means that
people in those countries have a really
simple way to explain where they live
today for me poor address English and
annoying frustration but for billions of
people it's a huge business inefficiency
severely hampers their infrastructure
growth and can cost lives we're on a
mission to change that three words at a
time thank you
[Applause]